les plus beaux sourires des
professionnels de la protection de
l'enfance du département étaient de
sortie pour cette journée consacrée aux
droits de l'enfant
des dizaines d'ateliers ont permis à nos
enfants de s'exprimer et droits de
l'enfant ces choses qui a le droit que
l'enfant a le droit de faire comme quoi
quand le faire son travail comme aller à
l'école comme
ont joué jeudi le doigt et à des
activités animaux qu'ils ont tout
compris
j'espère encore des droits et des
devoirs dans le droit de manger avant
une maison est soignée et à l'école un
thé l'essentiel une famille et vivre des
droits fondamentaux qu'il faut rappeler
chaque jour
surtout quand on sait que 121 mille
enfants réunionnais vivent dans des
familles sous le seuil de pauvreté
ajoutez à cela les actes de violence
conjugale présents sur le territoire
mais il n'ya aucune fatalité donc
comment on peut faire c'est de faire
appel aux services du département
on est en difficulté il ya les services
de l'aide sociale qui existe aujourd'hui
l'aide sociale c'est plus la date
d'avant on n'est pas là pour retirer des
enfants on est là pour aider les
familles à bien entendu certaines
situations nécessitent qu il y ait un
déplacement des enfants qu'on allait pmi
qui existe aussi les pmi sont là pour
accompagner les maires bien avant la
naissance
après la naissance et jusqu'à l'âge de 6
ans enfin on a les services de
polyvalence du département qui accueille
au delà de 6 ans et qui accueille toutes
les personnes donc là vous avez une
difficulté quelle qu'elle soit passager
ou non vous rencontrez un travailleur
social un diagnostic est fait et on vous
propose un plan d'action je faisais moi
dénommé ça comme ça en tout cas des
solutions pour pouvoir vous aider à
résoudre votre difficulté
les jeunes du conseil départemental des
jeunes ont donné de la voix pour
l'occasion
il
[Musique]
à quoi ça sert de vouloir
vous voyez les marmailles d'aujourd'hui
nos enfants ben ils n'ont pas demandé à
être à être dans la misère ils n'ont pas
demandé à souffrir d'occident na qui
souffrent on doit les accompagner
et c'est le rôle du département le
département est là pour justement faire
en sorte que chaque enfant qui naît à la
réunion que l'ine dans les eaux comme
dans les bas valais doit pas les mêmes
chances de réussir sa vie
pour exemple département accompagne 2234
enfants au titre de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance des enfants qui feront aussi
la société des deux bords
un an